okay I guess we can start good afternoon
my name is Etienne Onaga I'm a director
of developer experience at Red Hat my
tree I handle is Atiya Naga and today
we're going to talk about migrating to
microservices databases in particular
about relational databases so it's my
first time here in Porto I enjoyed
everything so far even though it has
been just a couple of hours I had the
opportunity to go to Cafe Santiago and
have a flaccid zinnia which is really
good by the way a bit heavy though and
just some curious facts I'm a Brazilian
Japanese that's why I speak Portuguese
even though people don't expect me to
speak Portuguese here yeah most I also
happen to be a Java champion and a
Microsoft MVP and as far as Gugu can
tell me I'm the first and so far only
one and I'm also at the DEF CON Rockstar
which is the largest software developer
conference and Latin America and for
today I hope we can make a raffle so I
brought this talk is based on this book
which I published from Weaver Riley
migrated into micro service databases so
everything I'm going to talk with you
today
you have everything here in more detail
format so but if you want a hard copy of
the book here's the deal you have to go
to Twitter follow me at the Onaga take a
picture of the session and mention a Tia
Naga and hash tag and this seaport oh if
you do that all of that I have an
application which is open-source
it's available on my github ienaga you
just have to trust that that version I'm
running is the same one that is
available github ok but if everything
goes fine I'm just gonna pull all of the
tweets and randomly pick the five
winners that I have for this session
okay but if you don't get a hard copy of
the book here's the next tip right the
Red Hat developer program bought the
royalties of the electronic version so
if you want to get
PDF bub or mommy for free you can go to
this URL bitly monitor micro GB and get
the electronic version of this book okay
so unfortunately we only have one hour
to be discussed this discussed in this
subject it's a very extensive topic so
I'm going to cover in general terms what
we have on the book but if you want
anything in more detail you can always
go to the to the full book and another
thing that is important for me to answer
is that why did I decide to write this
book I've been discussing micro-services
for about six to seven years and
distributed season for even longer but
when I started the discussion about
micro services everybody was asking me
well you're talking about micro services
there are many other people that are
talking about micro service too
you have some books but everybody talks
about the behavior part or their
architecture parts of the micro services
architecture but nobody talks about them
maybe their hardest part which is the
data how do I deal with distributed data
how do i split how integrate later and
to be honest I didn't have a proper
answer for that so I started with
research about 4 years ago and the first
initial results of my research I was
able to publish as a book and a mom
writes in another book about the subject
in particular about not only about
relational databases but distributed
data in general and event-driven
architecture I told the editors that I
would be finishing by October this year
but as you know I'm a software developer
so I'm very good in estimates so I'm not
sure if October will be the real
deadline this book I told the editors
that I would be finishing by February
and I finished in December of the next
year ok so we might have some delay but
so far everything is is on track because
I was writing the book and doing the
research at the same time for this new
book I have all of the contents already
I just need to to calm down and sit and
write the pages ok and it's going to be
a bigger book too
but since we have to discuss the subject
migrating to micro service databases I'd
like to start with zero down time when
we're except talking about DevOps and
micro services of course if you want to
be really able to deploy smaller batch
sizes and have more frequent releases
into production we need zeros on time
we're not allowed to just shut down all
services because somebody's updating one
micro service into production so if you
want to achieve zero downtime your
deployment pipelines you need the first
and more the simplest requirements is to
have Bluegreen deployments which means
that in your deployment architecture you
need in your production environment at
least choose similar environments each
one of them capable of handling a
hundred percent of your requests into
production at the same time and what
happens is that you have a blue and
green deployments I want to release a
new version and just choose one of the
environments for example the green I
just released a new version into the
green of environments I get the ruler I
route all of my deployment requests to
the green environments if everything
went well okay I just can can just
update the blue deployments or else I
can go it something went wrong don't
worry I have the previous version still
working on the blue environment I just
asked the ruler to switch back the the
request to the old version until I
figure out what went wrong with the new
version so this is a very safe approach
and allow us to perform zero downtime
deployments you just need to take a bit
of care what you're doing with your code
but as I said before code is the easy
part
we're talking about behavior most people
can figure out what do you need to do
with your software to have multiple for
multiple and once a month at least two
versions running at the same time in
production but when we're talking about
States which is means the data that is
being stored usually in a relational
database for Enterprise Information
Systems it's much harder so how if you
have to change anything in your database
if you're changing the schema of your
data of your database or if you're
change changing the semantics of the
data that is store in the database how
do you deal with multiple
versions running at the same time in
production so one of the I think one of
the greatest results of my research was
that four years ago I was able to talk
with many people and many different
people and teams worldwide trying to
figure out how they solve this problem
even though it was a side-effect of my
research I have to tell you that it's by
far the most popular chapter of my book
how to do this kind of thing zero
downtime deployments with relational
databases in production environments so
the question was how do I do that with
relational databases and the answer goes
through you're not allow it to perform
migrations manually anymore and
technically in the database word
migration is the set of sequel
statements code statements that you
apply to your database to change your
database schema version from one version
to the other so usually it's a lot of
sequel statements that you need to apply
that and in the past we used to just get
this sequel statement a big one like a
hundred line sequel statement sent to
your DBA through email and ask he or she
- well whenever upgrade the version of
my artifact in production you just
please apply the sequel statements
usually they forget that's why I have
problems when you release into
production well we can't do that anymore
we need to automate everything and the
two most popular database migration
tools in the Java world and because I'm
a Java person but after the research I
just realized that most of the people
are using these tools flyway and liquid
based they just just happened to be
developing in Java but they work of
course in any environments they support
XML sequel even code based migrations so
they are very flexible and if you're
using flyweight you can even use
flyweight to upgrade the the schema of
your secret life that are bases Android
devices so it's a very they are very
flexible tools I just note that from my
research again the only developer word
where the students were not as popular
as the Java Ward were
the Ruby on Rails word just because Ruby
on Rails has Beauty migrations so they
don't need an external to for that okay
so how can we achieve with these two's
zero downtime migrations the answer is
we need our migrations to be back and
forward compatible which means that the
schema versions of our relational
database I have a the previous version
needs to be compatible with the next
version and the new version needs to be
compatible with the previous version how
can we achieve that so instead of
issuing a hundred line sequel statements
to my DBA I'm going to split that big
sequel statements big file into smaller
files maybe even though it's technically
possible to have more than one statement
per file if you start a beginning with
this kind of thing it's better to have
like one single statement per migration
it's much easier for you to control even
though technically if you're changing
different sets of tables at the same
time it could be allow it for you to
have like more than one statement per
migration but just leave that to advance
it cases also if you use it to issue
update statements your database like if
you have a table with 1 billion billion
rows and yet that update statement took
30 seconds or 5 minutes to update and we
within that time you had like a lock in
your table it would mean downtime into
production you're not allowed to do that
anymore so you need to shard your
updates which is the technical term in
your data were to mean that you have to
split your update statements into
smaller statements until you can measure
and appropriate downtime so you have if
you have a lock of like 200 milliseconds
and 200 200 milliseconds is good enough
for you is for you use case for your use
case you just found the perfect bed size
so you need to shard your updates and
just an example this one is wrong but
just to tell you what you know what to
you might need to change so if you use
it to issue an outer table customer
rename something to other thing maybe
you have to split this statement into
multiple smaller ones like add column
multiple updates and then maybe later
delete
okay so this is to give you the overall
idea and I was able to collect for four
different scenarios that developers
worldwide are using to apply zero
downtime migrations and I'll warn you
that most of the time that when people
see it for the first time they say oh
that is a lot of work just to it just to
achieve zero downtime migrations but
everybody that tried to apply this zero
danta migrations in productions then
never look back after the applying that
because this is not the only way to
achieve zero downtime aggressions this
is their only this is the safest way for
you to be updating your database schema
into production because you never lose
the previous data that you were working
on because you never issued destructive
statements to your production database
that's why people are so excited about
using this in production and again the
first time I presented these migrations
to an audience there were many people in
the audience that just raised their
hands and told me I don't think this
work they really like to challenge
especially especially when people are
talking about something new but even
four years after I present to them I
just asked them well if you think it
doesn't work
I just need one example that doesn't
work it proves that I'm wrong but I
didn't receive any so far which might
mean that it might be working but if you
want to really check you can go to my
github again I have a repo called zero
downtime migrations where I show an
application using different migrations
and I evolve the application through
different versions and you can have two
versions running at the same time with
different database schemas and they both
work so you can roll back you can move
forward you never lose any data and your
application still behaves correctly okay
so I can go to the heater but of course
I always ask people to try because if
anything is wrong I'm the first one to
that wants to learn to to know if
anything really is wrong so I can fix it
okay so we're going to discuss very
quickly because I don't have much time
to be discussing that but the scenarios
are at a column rename a column change
in type of format of a column and the
leader column how does it work so first
scenario
the column so you're not allowed to do
do outer table at column and nor you
have to do this at least these four
steps into production each one of these
numbers 1 2 3 & 4 are different versions
that we're releasing into production so
on the first release you just use issue
outer table at column you won't be using
the column yet
so second version your code computes the
read value and writes to the new column
when I say compute if you can compute
the value from other fields in your
application you do that or I also just
assume a default value that could mean
something to your application okay third
release which could be multiple ones
like 3 3.1 3.2 you update they update
the data using shards are you issue the
update statements to update a new column
to your database and number 4 code reads
and write from the new column if you did
all of these steps in sequence and you
apply the dent all of that to your
database you successfully applied zero
downtime aggression where each one of
these versions is back and forward
compatible at the same time and this is
the simplest one I have to emphasize
that between each one of these versions
each one of these releases you're going
to open your sequel CLI and you are
going to issue multiple select statement
to your database just to check if your
application is writing the right
information or if anything went wrong go
to your migration okay fix somebody
raise the hand
yes yeah but there is no old column I'm
just Eddie yeah no but there is no old
column there is nothing and there is the
new because when you have a node column
is the next scenario but I know and I to
be honest I won't try to think about
this complicated scenario while I'm
talking because of course I'm nervous
everything but if you can discuss later
we'll have plenty of time to be
discussed that but thanks for the
question
ok and second scenario this is the most
complicated one when I have to rename a
column into production so we need at
least six different steps so first step
outer table add column second version
your code reads from the old column and
writes to both why do you write to both
well you need both versions running at
the same time so further shown you copy
the data uses more charts fourth version
your code reads from the new column and
writes to both again you need to write
to both because the old version might
need to need it even just in case you
row back to 50 version your code reads
and writes from the new column and sixth
version you delete the column not
immediately but later and when I mean
the sixth step what do you do you just
leave the column there and you just open
your JIRA create a new ticket saying DBA
in your maintenance window just check if
nobody's really using this column
perform a backup and if you did that you
can successfully
really delete the column and why we just
do that later because the leading in a
column is a destructive statement if you
do that you lose the data and your
previous version won't be able to work
with that column anymore that's why we
do that
okay and next scenario change type and
format of a column and you can see these
are the exactly same steps which is a
good thing we're always rehearsing the
the same steps to perform this kind of
zero downtime migrations and for
scenario deletes a column which you
never do in production so be quiet
because again deleting a column as
destructive statement if you delete a
column you just lose everything that you
have the only the only thing that you
can do if you delete a column and you
need the previous versions is to restore
a backup which we if we ever did that
into production can be a very painful
thing I did that of course upgraded
version of one software in the weekend
and Monday morning I just realized that
oh why do we well we screwed up and I
called the DBA we need to restore the
backup from Saturday in the evening and
he just told me that well you know that
to restore the backup it takes 8 hours
right so it was a very very happy day in
my life ok so but so you never needed a
column but you decide to delete a
comment production you just change your
code stop reading the value but keeping
writing to the column because again your
previous version might need the data and
you might be wondering what if I remove
the fuse on my application that used to
get the value well you just have to
figure out and try to write some value
on the database that's meaningful to the
previous version okay and if you did
that maybe later when you know that
nobody is using that anything anymore
you can stop right into the column and
as the DBA to delete the column later on
the maintenance window what about my
referential integrity constraints not
new constraints and other kinds of
constraints the answer you have to drop
them and just recreate everything when
the migrations are done and you might be
wondering well referential integrity
constraints are just a safety net
because just these are just things that
the DBA puts on the database to prevent
us application developers from inserting
inconsistent data to the database so we
don't really require them to for
application to be running you know
though it's good in
most of the case is very cheap for you
to implement so but in this case if
you're responsible you're doing the
right thing you don't really need the
stuff working your production database
and this concludes the part where I talk
about zero downtime immigrations and you
might be wondering why are you talking
about that if the subject of this talk
is micro-services database because in
the past the downtime of the system was
equal to the downtime of the monolith
which was also equal and most of most of
the times when we're talking about
migrations to the downtime of your
database but if we're talking about
Microsoft's database databases
distributed architectures and well
you're not allowed to have downtime in
your system just because you have one of
your multiple maybe 20 micro services in
your architecture because that my
preserver see is updating their database
so I'm going to have downtime then if
you're doing that multiple times per day
then the other team is updating the
other macro service and I have downtime
the downtime is just multiply it so you
you well you're not allowed to have
downtime but even it's even worse if you
have them down time there is preventable
such as downtime from migrations and now
we're going to discuss the macro service
characteristics part of this talk Marti
Fowler did a very good nice job
collecting something and publishing them
on his blog there are at least nine
different characteristics of micro
services architectures but today I'm
only going to discuss this one the
centralized data management which means
that if the best frats is to start to
always start with the Moi's and then
after it grows you just decide to split
that into a macro service architecture
you just decide to pick one part that
might be a good bounded context in
domain driven design terminology you
Streck that into your macro service so
how can I achieve from the monolith and
extraction and achieve the goal of the
one database / macro service right if
you studied micro service a bit you know
that if you don't have one database by
micro service you basically have a
coupling on the data layer and have much
bigger issues which I won't be able to
discuss today but this is the basic goal
so one database by microservice but
again I always start with a monolithic
database and for some in some ways
only two splits and most importantly
I'll have to integrate the data later
because data has mass and just like in
gravity the more data you have the more
data it attracts because oh I need to
call you you need data correlation
enterprise information systems data is
never isolated from the other parts of
the system so you need to integrate and
make them work together so splitting you
so it's not easy but how integrate the
data and even though I can't help you to
decide which piece of the data do you
want to stretch or do you need to
stretch because that's a domain model
problem and you really well you need to
really dig into the domain model to be
able to strengthen the information that
you need but I can help you on how can
you integrate the data after you decided
which piece of information do you want
to subtract from your from your
monolithic data base but before I dig
into the answers I have to explain some
concepts very briefly for you first of
all some consistency models I don't know
if anybody here studied distributed
systems what I'm going to tell you right
now is an oversimplification of the
concepts just for teaching purposes and
I'm only going to discuss two different
models strong consistency and eventual
consistency in particularly a subtype of
eventual consistency which is a strong
eventual consistency which is different
from sequential eventual consistency and
explain why how does it work and then a
strong consistency system if I have like
five nodes in my system and I decided
that I have a variable which I equals to
three and I decide to update this
variable I now is equal to five and of
course in each one of these nodes I have
clients connected to these nodes in a
strong consistent system which is the
system that you believe that you have
when you're using database transactions
but again sorry for lying for you you
don't really have strong consistency
even in your relational database because
that's very expensive but suppose that
you supposing that you would have
this kind of thing in a strong
consistent system when I decide to
update a variable all of the nodes in
the system they need to agree on the new
value before anybody reads the new value
okay so until that information
propagates in all of the nodes and
everybody agrees on it everybody is
reading the old value okay so it's very
similar to what you think that you have
in relational databases and eventual
consistency in a pure eventual
consistent system if you have five nodes
rights are allowed in any node so if I
equals to free and I decide that well
here I'm going to update I now equals to
five and at the same time in the other
node
somebody's updating I equals to 10 and
then when this information propagates
you have a conflict and the system needs
to decide which one is correct which for
some use cases might be valid for
enterprise information systems usually
we don't accept this kind of use case we
want the truth information and you might
be thinking well the last right wins but
if you're using the last right means
that you need some kind of synchronizer
and we learned that we can't rely on
second eyes o'clock unless your Google
like if using some sort of distributed
database like spanner you might have
strong consistency between a global
distributed Network but just because
Google had enough money to launch their
own satellite network and I'm pretty
sure that everybody here does have the
same amount of money okay but if you
don't you can't rely on global
synchronizer talk you need to solve this
problem in other way that's why instead
of using pure eventual consistency in
distributed in enterprise micro service
architectures we're using another
subtype of eventual consistency which is
a strong eventual consistency how does
it work in this kind of model you choose
one of the nodes to be the canonical
source of information you in this node
this is the source of the truth and
rights are only allowed on these nodes
so basically you choose on this node now
I equals to five and this this
information gets propagated to the other
nodes and while the other clients
connected to the other nodes I still
reading the old value clients connected
to this node are
already reading the new value so if I
say I equals to seven other people might
be reading like I equals to five and if
later some end this for information for
example propagates now two nodes have
seven and the other three have five then
somebody decide to update i equals to
nine on this node so what happens in
this case clients connected here are
reading a nine clients connected to this
node are reading a seven and clients
connected to the other nodes as you
reading a five so what happens in this
kind of model you always have correct
data but the data might be outdated with
different latency values okay so this
one is fresher this one is oldest but
all of the data is correct they just
might be outdated with different latency
times okay and why is it different from
sequential consistency because in a
macro in an employee in an enterprise
microsoft's architecture the clients are
sticky so you have a database these
micro services this micro service is
always connected to the same database
you don't have micro services hopping
nodes from database to perform the
readings so because in a sequential
system you might happen that oh I'm
reading a 5 then you connect to the
other node I mean II reading a 9 and you
might get back to a node value okay but
it doesn't happen in enterprise
information systems and that's why we're
using strong eventual consistency
instead of pure sequential eventual
consistency ok so this is the first
concept and have in mind strong eventual
consistency because that's the model
that people are using worldwide to in
enterprise information systems for micro
service architectures second concept
crud and secure s we're going to learn
the difference between them crud is an
architecture a very simple and common
architecture where all of the four
operations create read update and delete
which means their rights and read
informations are performant using the
same domain model what does it mean if I
have a customer micro service I have a
customer class in my domain model and I
have a
customer table in my database and its
dependencies if I want to write
something to the database using an ORM
just create a new instance of customer I
populate the value as the ORM to save it
to the database if I want to queue it
information I just creates a Curie I
retrieve customer objects from my
database and X and expose it to the user
so crud
very simple recommended for like 92% of
the use cases it's so simple that these
days our tools we have tools to
automatically generate the code it just
you just give a domain model it's
automatically scaffolds everything for
you and exposes you in a beautiful REST
API or even creates a beautiful
interface for you so this is the model
that was particularly popularized in the
90s and 2000's so and if you think that
about traditional enterprise information
systems we had a certain proliferation
of this kind of model because it allows
well workflow where you have different
kinds of grants screens or the user
needs to input the devices but the
process to achieve a business goal is
external to the tool so if you're using
like tools like s AP or anything else
but you have a lot of creds to be
filling up to achieve a certain business
goal you just have to go to this form
fill it go to other form you just stand
your value you go to another form just
feel something go to the other form just
feel something
the process is external to the to which
is very nice because it makes the to
very flexible you can adjust your you
can use the tool for many different
process it's very nice because Cotton's
can charge you a lot because they have
to teach you the process because it's
cirno' to the two and it works very well
the problem is that we've digital
transformation these days you need to be
much more efficient in certain processes
so you're doing last things but the
things that you're doing you need to be
extremely efficient so this kind of
architecture might not be the right one
for certain user cases in your business
domain and for therefore this particular
case you might want a richer domain
model and some of the patterns that you
might need to apply when you're doing
that is for example
yes I was reading secure as the name was
pointed approximately 12 years ago by
Greg young he didn't create the disparen
he just created the name and I suppose
be reading his published documents about
the reasons behind this parent and
secure RS is a very fancy name for
another simple architecture command kiri
responsibility segregation which started
which derive it from sick us command
kiri separation which was first
published by Bertrand Meyer in a faux
book
what better Meyer told us is what that
well if you have you need to separate
your interfaces between commands
operations and QE operations so if
you're talking about Java or C sharp
you're just creating a Java or C sharp
interface for write operations and read
the operations and we didn't know
exactly why at the time almost thirty
years ago but these days we learned that
oh if you have different interfaces now
it's very easy for you to use different
technologies for reading and writing you
just need to switch the implementation
for the right interface for example and
you have a different writing right
technology so if you did everything
correctly in your legacy system it might
be easy for you to be doing today okay
and command key responsibility
segregation is an evolution of the cqs
again it's really recommended that you
have separate service interfaces but if
you didn't do that don't worry you can
still have a secure s pattern
implemented in your architecture how
does it work and I'm pretty sure that
most of you already use it and create a
security architecture you just didn't
know that I have this name so if you
have a secure s pattern in New York
Thatcher you basically custom again if I
want to write things to develop the
database I just create a customer
instance and write the customer to the
customer tables but somebody who
requires from me reports and on this
report I just want the ID the name and
the phone number of the customer but the
customer table is very big has a lot of
fields if I just decide to use a crud
I'm going to QE
entire database into memory too just to
generate a report with three fields so
what do you do you create a custom
keyring select ID name and phone number
from customer and you you and you
populate these things in a customer DTO
and you use this DTO in memory to
generate your reports congratulations
you created the simplest possible form
of security architecture you're using
different domain models customer class
to write and using customer DTO to read
and you are correct the reason that we
did that in the past was number one
performance using credit for some music
aces to slow it consumes to memory so we
needed to use the QRS to improve the
performance of our system but these days
when we're talking about distributed
data we are using security secur as
pattern to solve other kinds of problems
that our performance again but we have
other requirements to be solved to so
and this is the most basic
implementation but this is the most
interesting one for distributed data
secure is with separate data stores and
if you ever created a view in your
database and you issued Curie's against
that view you created a secure s you
implemented the secure as pattern in
your architecture we have separate write
and data stores because customer is too
populated and being written on the right
that is tor but when you need to carry
something you created a separate data
store a customer view and you're
retrieving your customer GTOs to from
your read data store which is the
customer view that's a security
architecture we have separate data
stores and in the previous example where
I needed a report with just ID name and
phone number if I needed an another
report with our DNA mail a name and
email what would I do
I would create another custom query
select ID name and email from customer I
would create another DTO very likely
customer DTO to even the
it's a terrible name and we used that we
would use that DTO to generate our
reports so you realize that usually in
this pattern you have one single right
model customer class but you might have
multiple Reid models depending on the
requirements of your system okay so
right is usually one but read the data
stores or read the domain models can be
multiple in your system okay
keep in mind as I said strong eventual
consistency is the model that we're
using and secure RS with separate data
stores is the pattern that we're going
to apply to our macro service
architecture this is what people are
using worldwide and last but not least I
have to discuss a bit about secure s and
even sourcing and if you look at the
gradient box
you learned that secure s was created
because of event sourcing event sourcing
is a very old architecture but the term
again is not that old it might be have
being coined like fifteen or twenty
years ago at most but it's a very old
concept it just we people didn't use
this name so what happened in the 2000s
people were thinking about the
traditional model of storing data into a
database which was I only store the
current state of my data so if I have a
customer if I curated database what do I
know about the customer I know the
current data I don't know the past data
from the customer so what was the
address ten years ago of that customer I
have no idea okay because I'm only
storing the current data in my in my
database and this is the traditional way
of thinking and again it works really
well but 15 years ago maybe 20 people
decided all we have this thing called
event sourcing and the definition of
events or C is that the state of the
data is not a snapshot in my database
the state of the data is a stream of
events and if you ever worked on the
bank system the classic example of when
sourcing works like this if I have a
bank system I have want to know how much
money I have in my
bank account I don't store them amount
of money in a table and a column and row
in my database what do I do I create the
transaction table and I just keep
writing debit and credit operations and
you have the benefit of this kind of
depth and credit which is sum and
subtract these operations are CR DT
which means that you have conflict free
resolution data types doesn't matter the
order in which you apply the operations
the result is always the same so if
everybody starts with a zero amount of
money if the order doesn't matter which
mean it means that the clock doesn't
matter you can later add a transaction
that was late and it used to have the
correct value okay so if everybody
starts with zero and I just keep adding
and subtracting adding and subtracting a
debit and credit debits and credits you
compute how much money do you have in
your bank account well zero must plus
minus plus minus you know how much money
do you have in your bank account
benefits of this architecture you have
very fast rights because you for the
right data store you can use a database
that is an append-only feistiest file
system it's very performant for writes
on the other hand you have a free
auditing logging because if you know how
did you reach that value you just look
at the transaction log you can figure
out you can just calculate or everything
over again you have a free time machine
if you want to learn how was the state
of your bank account five years ago six
months three days and three hours you
just start from zero and apply all of
the transactions until that point of
time okay so it's a free time machine on
the other hand you might be wondering to
read the data is extremely is low I have
to start from zero and apply all of the
transactions over again to know how much
money do I have in my bank accounts now
and it gets even slower than more bank
accounts that you have and the more
transactions that you have so this is a
scenario fifteen years ago people were
thinking about transitioning from
snapshot systems to events or systems
but they had this problem with
performance then Greg young coined the
term secure s which we're now tying
secure s architectures secure s read the
stores with the mid sourcing so the
rights
are still events are seen as sources we
are getting the rights into an
append-only file system or a database or
something and synchronously or
asynchronously we create another table
with another column with other rows
which are updated with a cache
information okay so the rights go to
this data store but the reads come from
here and again you might be thinking
well the cache might get wrong
eventually but since you're using event
sourcing if you want to do that and
that's what every banking system does
during the night you just get a snapshot
from the how much money you had in your
bank account yesterday you apply all of
the transactions from the day again and
you just check well does the cash has
the same value as the computed value
from now if it matches okay next next
row if it doesn't then somebody raises
the flag Oh somebody needed to need to
manually check this bank account because
something seems wrong that's the
auditing procedure that banks uses
overnight every single day so that's how
you're tying secured s we're even
sourcing so it can have very fast writes
and an audit trail and a time machine
and you can still have good performance
using secure s read data models okay
just have in mind again many people are
using this kind of architecture in
distributed data architectures not
everybody okay so you might be wondering
event sourcing or not but secure s
definitely if you're using an enterprise
information system you're very likely to
end up using a secure s read the restore
and why did I tell all that because
after all of these years developing and
talking to people that were creating the
distributed architectures the
traditional path that most people use to
fail when deploying this tabular data is
this one well I have a monolith I
decided that I want to strike this piece
of information for example again
customer customer extract that to a
customer micro service now I have a
customer macro service on the customer
data the rest of the monoliths still
needs the customer data so what do you
do well we did everything
right so all of the customer data is
accessed for from the accustomary Dao so
what do I need to do well just create a
rest endpoint here for HTTP just
whenever I need the customer data
I just issue remote cows to my remote
endpoint and get the data back so in
theory it should work you deploy that in
production you fail miserably because it
doesn't scale so if you have unless you
have a very low requirement on reads and
writes these architecture will fail and
I witness that many times in the past
years so when and just oh my god it
doesn't scale because it's like many
orders of magnitude slower so what do we
do developers they tend to think like
well it's as low we have a performance
problem how do you serve a performance
problem for data you had a cache right
you just oh we're just going to add an
internal memory cache in my application
and now every time we will lower the
workload because we have the data
locally and everything else now you have
even more problems of consistency but
performance gets better but if it's
faster but it's not fast enough what do
you think next step web cache is not big
enough what do you do oh I need an
external cache so you deploy an external
cache system connected to the Romagna
leaf to store all of the reads and now
performance seems ok but then you
realize well I have like a thousand
reports in my monolith and I used to do
the join of the customer information
directly from the database and since
everything is written to sequel strings
it's not typesafe you never know that
it's going to happen well not really but
you usually you only learn that people
are using this data when you run into
production because again in string based
programming and now you have a problem
we are going to need to rewrite all of
my reports or any other QE that uses
customer and but almost all the data is
in the database using relational tables
and I have objects in my cache so I used
to do the joins in the database now I
have to queue the data and do the
joining memory just to generate reports
then somebody usually the most
experience person heaven has an idea why
don't we just create a copy table which
had exactly same structure as before and
we just find a way to get the rights
that are being written in the other end
points to get synchronized to our local
copy of the data well congratulations
what did you just do you created a
secure s read data model that is using
strong eventual consistency to get
updated now I'm going to just explain to
you what are the different techniques
that you can use to apply to update the
remote data into your secure s read the
restore and again before somebody asks
me I'm going to tell you I'm describing
the particular user case of Enterprise
Information Systems because I believe
then the software development world we
have some kind of separation between the
problems that we solve Enterprise
Information Systems you have very
complex business logic and complex
relations between the data that you're
manipulating okay but the volume of the
data that you're manipulating is not
that huge compared to most interactive
startup business models where have
simpler business models but the amount
of data that you need to handle is much
bigger so the focus here is the problem
is business model the other kind of
software that's remodeling the problem
here is infrastructure okay so we tackle
these different problems with different
solutions I'm going to discuss just
enterprise information problem because I
believe that were like 90% of the
developers worldwide are coding ok
so in my initial initial research I was
able to gather nine different techniques
that people were using worldwide some of
them I don't agree but I'm not judging
and just reporting what people used and
seem to be working for them okay and
these are shared tables database views
materialized views triggers
transactional codes ETL data
authorization event sourcing and change
data captures and we go we're going to
run very quickly for them and again
everything I'm saying to you today you
can read in my book in much more detail
and in a much better pace I'm pretty
sure so share tables means means that
macro service and monolith are reading
and writing from the same tables in the
same database I I considered this one a
hack of course I don't recommend it
I don't recommend it's an anti-pattern
but it's very fast integrate like I need
something deployed today
well you don't change anything just read
and write from the same database you
have strong consistency because you're
using database transactions in the same
database and it has low cohesion in the
high coupling what's the problem with
this one is the monoliths and macro
service are different teams and this
becomes the perfect excuse for not
changing anything at all anymore
Microsoft's team says I can't change the
database because the monolith is using
that one on this team says I can't
change the database because Microsoft's
team is doing that so you're just stuck
in this thing forever so if you decide
to use shared tables as an integration
technology you just say well we're
deploying this today first thing for the
nest back backlog is we're going to
choose a better integration strategy for
our data now you need to change change
this immediately immediately or it will
get stuck forever okay second
integration database views and when I
say in separate databases I know again
for Enterprise Information Systems it's
not like it's not something real to ask
for oh I need a separate separate Oracle
instance for each one of my micro
services ok it's going to be a very
expensive build so when the same
separate database it might mean that
well you have a single database instance
running and you have separate schemas
we've separate users and permissions for
each one of your micro services that's
the that's a nice approach nice and
reliable approach which also means that
if you have this kind of centralized
infrastructure even though you might be
thinking well availability availability
might suffer because I have a single
instance but you know in the other hand
for IT you have centralized backups and
everything else
let's be honest if your central Oracle
database goes down you think really that
any part of your system we use to keep
working in enterprise information world
I don't think so okay so that's why even
when I say one database per
micro-service you can have like
different schemas on the same instance
many people are doing that and it's not
a an unforgivable sin database view if I
have micro-service tables here I creates
a view on the other database for the
monolith to keep working that's the
easiest one to implement all of the DBMS
vendors currently support views you
might have some performance issues
depending on the view depends on the
database and how you create everything
you always have strong consistency
because you're writing directly to the
hot data and deformation is always fresh
one database must be reachable by the
other which means that you have remote
instances or separate instances on
Oracle you need to use the Billings and
some DBA is cursed me for that because
they say it doesn't work I'm not judging
I'm just saying that some people are
using and for their requirements it
worked so you shouldn't be discarding
some solutions just because some people
say oh it won't work well depending on
your requirements it might work okay
it's updatable depending on the mms
support because in Oracle you might have
updatable views but we don't recommend
that because it's if you allow writes in
more than one system you don't have a
single canonical node and it will be
very difficult for you to change your
architecture later if you decide to
allow dates in multiple nodes database
materialized view if we have a
performance issue with views usually the
next step is to change the view to a
materialized view so you have usually
had better performance you might have
stronger eventual consistency if you
decide to update the materialized view
on commit you have a strong consistency
but be careful it's a performance killer
the most common way is to have a chrome
trigger updating the materialized view
or you ask you do a refresh on the Manns
on your system one database must be
reachable the other if you is an Oracle
means a DB link and I use this
integration strategy -
in the past like five six years ago we
had a particular use case the customer
had a database in their data center they
needed to expose a piece of information
into a service on the cloud so what we
created we went to Amazon RDS we created
an Oracle instance exactly the same
version as they had in the datacenter
and we kept discussing the entire day
how we were going to integrate the data
and then in the end of the day I just
said to them well why don't we create a
remote materialized view everybody left
they cursed me but when I ride home I
say I want to try it see if it works so
it took me 15 minutes to create a room
DB linked database materialized view I
tested that we were using the refresh
on-demand and I just put a cron trigger
to refresh that every 30 minutes because
the requirements of the systems were
that the data the latency for the data
updates were 30 minutes so I was allowed
to have a 30 minute delay so I put a
crunch figure on my system to refresh
the materialized view for every 30
minutes
and it worked because the Refresh took
20 minutes to be completed I still had
10 minutes left so even though most if
not all of the DBA said it was a pretty
hack it worked and it has been working
the past five or six years very well so
that's another option I'm not judging
yeah especially because I did this
myself but and again it's updatable
depending on DBMS support you can also
use triggers have Microsoft database you
put a trigger on the database every time
and anything is changed you update the
remote endpoint you have strong
consistency you if you do that on commit
one that a base must be reachable by the
other because it means you again you can
use that DB link but this one again I
consider this to be a hack but I'm not
judging it only works for a
point-to-point integration like I have
one micro service one other endpoint one
micro service one monolith and why is
that because you have tight coupling
between the points every time you change
here you have to change the other side
every time you change to this side you
need to change the trigger
so it doesn't scale it works on if you
have one or two integrations okay but if
that's the use case of your team maybe
that's a reasonable solution transaction
code is the same case as trigger but
instead of using triggers you might be
using store procedures or distributed
transactions XA or two-phase commit and
you also have strong consistency you
have possible cohesion and company
issues because again only really works
for point to point integration you might
have performance issues it's updatable
even though we don't recommend and how
does it work I have this ability
transactions if I decided to integrate
every time somebody changed here I need
to change here here and here here
well it's a cascading change if I change
here I have to change here for hey I
change here I have to change everywhere
so again it doesn't scale it's only
feasible for point-to-point integrations
ETL tools if you ever use it clink vo
Pentaho - builder to be creating your
reports you can also use this tools to
extract the data from our remote
database and create a secure RS read
data model in your local database these
tools you have lots of different tools
to be able they are able to do that
requires an external trigger which is
usually a contributor button on the
interface you can aggregate multiple
data sources it's always eventual
consistent because by the time you read
it it's already updated it's a regional
integration which is not a bad thing
who did that well there were some things
were they already had a person that was
responsible for the ETL - they were
performing multiple integrations for
multiple different kinds of reports
every day and it was their very first
integration I just need to consume that
data why are we going to waste like
maybe I sprint a week or two weeks be
creating this architecture to propagate
the things now I need a broker or others
or other kind of stuff to be propagating
the data they just ask the TL guy well
it's just another QE that I have to put
in my tool and we'll get that at the
copy of the data for you so if you
already have an ETL person in your team
maybe that's a reasonable
solution of course you have more
integration than than a couple or if
your integration get need need to spend
multiple endpoints or need more complex
integrations ETL czar not feasible but
again in some use cases people use ETL
tools and it workers for them data
virtualization this one is a very nice
solution even though I only met three
different teams that use it data
virtualization solutions all of them
were banks two of them were using the
Red Hat
data utilization product and the other
one was using the Cisco solution for
data routinization
how does it work none of them bought the
solution just to the point
micro-services but all of them were very
happy that they already had the two and
they were that they were able to use it
to create their macro service
architecture because because why is that
because they were able to fail throw
everything up out and build everything
from scratch again without changing the
physical database because if you think
that's reading that database is hard
splitting it right it's almost
impossible in the same time a first time
usually you're going to do something
wrong a name then maybe you have the
wish to put things back it's even more
complicated okay so what did they do if
you use the database data virtualization
basically you just have the data in the
bottom layer you use you create virtual
databases and you have you can have
multiple clients consuming the virtual
databases and you might have real-time
access because it's just a
virtualization layer you have
performance issues you can add a cache
layer here these twos they all provide
support for caching and it's you can
have a write integration even though we
don't recommend that and how do they do
that well I want to know which piece of
information I can extract from my
monolith if I'm using that
virtualization solution I just create I
just can create like a virtual database
customer virtual database and play with
the macro service oh we did it wrong
it's the wrong piece of information to
track because one pattern every time I
change data here I need to change it
there
every time I change change change change
data there I need to change it here too
which means that you probably extracted
the wrong piece of information
oh yeah maybe we need to strike it
differently or a different model then if
you're using physical data base is going
to be very complicated if you're using a
VDD delete the VDD and create another
one okay so they they were able to do
that trial and error move that database
until they got the right solution and
that's that's examples that I have to
give you only three user cases and at
least one of them they just decided well
the VDB solution for the secure s model
is working so well I think we're stick
to the virtual virtualized a solution
instead of creating another piece of
architecture just to integrate the data
event sourcing is the architecture that
explained it for the state of the data
is a stream of events you have all the
team the Machine eventual consistency
because usually Europe dating the data
are synchronously using a message bus
and because of the message bus you can
achieve usually much higher scalability
than you rather than using a synchronous
requests and the problem with in event
sourcing even though I told you the
benefits before the problem with event
sourcing that I've seen in the field is
that many people are selling event
sourcing as the best possible solution
for integration between distributed
systems and I think I might agree that
event sourcing for many user cases might
be the ideal solution but it's very hard
to achieve this idea of architecture in
your system the problem that I witness
net is that it's very hard for you to do
event sourcing right in fact I only know
one team that needed to write on the
first time and that just because they
were fine I can disclose the name of the
company but it's a worldwide finance
company but it's not a Mac and they did
that they had a monolith in a mainframe
and did you decide to create a Microsoft
a chewy events are seen on Amazon and
using sqs and everything else and they
did the events right on the first time
just because the events didn't change in
the past 40 years so they took the same
team some people were very
and this hour we're going to model any
events and they just had everything but
in their in their hearts they could say
what types of the events you have your
system they just knew it by a heart so
it was very easy for them to implement
this is event sourcing because they had
all of the events in their minds and
they created everything but so what's
the plot if you have a legacy system
which is doing snapshotting I don't
recommend you to change the legacy
system to create events or see because
events sourcing is very hard but if
you're creating a new piece of software
in your system and then you might
consider one to consider event sourcing
because that's a really nice real real
nice solution especially for greenfield
projects and if you're doing that what I
do recommend is that stick to low level
events on your event sourcing we are
what our low level events create update
delete and stick to that because usually
you have fewer changes if you stick to
these kind of events
you just have change of type you don't
have change of semantics because people
think that oh I'm using events and I'm
using a broker
I have local coupling in my system in an
event-driven architecture the coupling
in your system is the type and semantics
of the events every time you change the
type every time you change the semantics
you have it will have a cascading change
you have to change all of the end points
that are consuming the events and it
gets really complicated if you have
multiple endpoints and you're changing
the events frequently so it's even worse
than using them all of it because in the
monolith you have if you use in a type
safe language like Java or C sharp you
can just refactor the code if you're
using the event you don't have this you
have to go through multiple code bases
and just realize what what changes
between the events so I'm recommending
what low-level events instead of domain
level events domain level events give
you power because you have semantics
instead of just created updated lead it
you have like how do I say credit limits
overflow well something like that like
use it too much credit or yeah you add
this
of semantics or you ask it an order to
be ship it to an address that is not
covered by your provider that's Anika
another kind of semantics that you can
add but again if you don't know the
types of events that you have in your
system very well you get issues
maintaining this code last one because
I'm over time change data capture which
I only learn it because of the my
research if you have a legacy system you
don't want to change the source code or
even you don't have the source code of
the system are you using data
integration your system which you have
which means there you have multiple
applications changing the database
directly on the same tables and the same
columns you don't have a appointing your
system when you can just capture all of
the change or all of the data change and
just brought the caster changes so you
have to connect directly into the
database transaction log CDC to connect
to the database transaction logs reads
that information and propagates that to
a message bus if you are ever used at
Oracle GoldenGate gotta get there's a
lot of things including CDC but the
thing that I want to show you is this
open source CDC to division if you're
wondering what is the name division the
be zoom the Red Hat engineers are very
good in naming things so they start with
DB and they wanted it to sound like
chemical elements so that the bees you
Wow ended up I know yeah they're not
good and how does it work very quickly
let me see if I can show you in 30
seconds what do I have here I have it
running in my machine I have my C code
database
I have Kafka which is a very nice
message broker that Vantage is that
cache contains the order on the same
partition you have a zookeeper which
store the shared state I have a my
sequel clients I have division runni I
have a Kafka watcher which just captures
the messages on the Kafka bus and
printed it to me let's see I have a
customer
have this idea thousand forest and crash
Marv if I get here and decide to do an
update I said it updated now her name is
Anne mahi let's see what happened in the
CAF kaaba's division detected on the
transaction log and printed this
messages on the Koshka bus oops I got
the quotes wrong so what happened DB
zoom propagates for me the schema before
and after the operation because it could
have been an alter table statement but
since it's an update statement the
interesting part is like before the
operation the payload was this first
name was n and the after is an mahi and
operation is an update and you have this
some sort of internal information and a
timestamp so if you're using this kind
of message to to update the data on your
remote secure as read restore I think
it's very easy for you to see oh I can
get the data future transform and just
update the data on my local database
with this kind of information okay and I
have much more that the division can do
but I'm over time and that's what I
wanted to share with you today
I hope it's helpful and thank you very
much
[Applause]